and finally new rule joe biden has to
admit that when he said about
republicans
with trump gone you're going to see
things change because these folks know
better
they know this isn't what they're
supposed to be doing he was wrong
and he has to come to terms with why
that was wrong which i'm going to
explain to you tonight
now i'm sure most of our viewers have
had the same thought i've had since
january 6th
how can they do it republicans come on
different policy positions okay sure
even life philosophies
fine list of priorities yes but this
sticking with the lie that an impeccably
run election was really stolen what
makes them do that
what is so great that it can make you
the big patriot with the flag pin on
your lapel
sell out your country on its most
fundamental principle
and the
and the answer is the title
the office the staff
the good table all that attention
and being the big cheese around the
office
congressman is literally the only job in
the world you can get with
so much prestige and so many perks while
being a complete
doofus with absolutely no skills
knowledge or
qualifications
[Applause]
name only almost any job dental
hygienist
rodeo clown dog walker
mall santa chicken sexer tilt-a-whirl
operator they all demand some kind of
definable skill set
not congress
[Applause]
you can be in jail and get this job you
can be deranged and get this job if you
have a heart attack
they just let your wife start doing the
job
all you need is a smile and a tie
i'd say you need a pulse but dead people
have been elected to congress
much more much more is required of an
immigrant taking the citizenship test or
the average voter
than the person who represents 750 000
voters in 48 states you can't vote
if you're in prison but in every state
you can run for congress
from prison
unremarkable people can get a remarkable
life
in congress and that's what keeps the
average republican backbencher in
fatso's thrall
sticking with trump guarantees them
something that's bigger than
faith family country or objective
reality
they get to keep the best job they could
ever get with absolutely nothing to
recommend their lazy
ignorant ass for it college degree
[Applause]
you don't even need a high school degree
lauren bobert didn't get one and she
sits on the budget committee
if she wasn't in congress she could
probably get a shift at a truck stop
dusting the jerky
but then she wouldn't have two paid-for
offices one in d.c
one in her district she wouldn't have a
staff that answers the phone
for her and kisses her ass all day no
one would put her on tv
and ask her opinions she couldn't go on
exotic
paid for trips i'm sorry i mean
fact-finding missions
a congress job is just so much better
than racking the weights at crossfit
which is what marjorie taylor-green did
before she set her crazy eyes on the
prize
and once you've got the gig it's yours
for life
the re-election rate in the house for
incumbents in 2020
was 95 that's better job security than a
pedophile priest
[Applause]
devin nunes i guess could mop up puke at
the sonic
but it would take him all day
would you hire this guy
but in congress puke mopper devin nunes
is a big deal
a man of respect when he walks in and
asks for the best table you know what
they say
they say sir this is a petsmart
the cheesecake factory is next door
last year a video went viral of a
walmart employee
quitting her job over the pa [ __ ] this
company [ __ ] this position and [ __ ] that
big lazy [ __ ] chris price i
[ __ ] quit
[Applause]
and here's texas representative chip roy
telling congress to take this job and
shove it
this institution is a sham and we should
adjourn and shut this place down
yeah the difference is the walmart
employee
actually quit
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
i love this chick can we look at it one
more time [ __ ] this company [ __ ] this
position and [ __ ] that big lazy [ __ ]
chris price i
[ __ ] quit
but chip roy he'll never quit because
there's no other jobs where a [ __ ] gets
paid to ride around in a limo
chip gets paid 175 grand a year free
medical great pension
with half the year off plus a million
and a half dollar a year
allowance for decorating the office and
sundries
oh also lobbyists blow him up
and he gets to be on tv for doing
nothing which as we all know is the
american dream
and
and by doing nothing i mean that
literally once you get elected you don't
have to actually
do anything there's no year-end
performance review
nobody calls you into an office and says
i don't think this is working out
you have essentially no boss well
except the voters that's the one thing
you got to do to keep all these
perks coming if your district is full of
people who think the election was rigged
or vaccines have microchips in them or
democrats eat babies
you have to agree and then repeat it in
congress
and they do nancy mace is a new house
member from south carolina the first
woman to graduate from the citadel
after january 6 she was outraged and
stood up to her party
giving a dozen interviews in a single
day condemning trump
now she won't even talk about it she
voted to oust liz
cheney for making the exact same case
she herself had made
a lot of people in america think she's a
patriot but she looks to me
like a traitor for the corner office
she supported an insurrection for the
likes
oh and one more thing this chris price
guy over at the walmart
he is a [ __ ] lazy [ __ ]
[Applause]
you